ces dernières heures sur le front sud la
ville d'odessa et pour la première fois
clairement en ligne de mire kiev indique
que sept missiles ont visé samedi la
ville portuaire bilan au moins à 8 morts
près de 20 blessés on retrouve sur place
l'envoyé spécial de france 24 tarek kai
qui est avec lux ragots bonjour tarek
odessa célèbre aujourd'hui la pâque
orthodoxe dans une atmosphère on imagine
présente après les attaques contre un
quartier résidentiel samedi
tout à fait comme vous l'avez dit au
dessin c'est là par la pâque orthodoxe
dans un contexte très particulier la
ville du sud avait été jusque là
épargnée par les frappes russe et hier
que vous l'avez dit sept missiles se
sont abattus sur des quartiers
résidentiels aux 17 donc qui a été pour
la première fois dans la ligne de mire
de l'armée russe avec un bilan officiel
de huit morts et de 18 blessés nous
étions arrivés à odessa vendredi dernier
et nous avions été frappée justement par
le climat plutôt paisible de la ville en
comparaison avec d'autres villes
ukrainiennes tout cela a changé hier
d'une minute à l'autre avec ces
nouvelles frappes russes qui ont visé
deux quartiers résidentiels les gens
justement se préparaient à fêter un pack
hier une des plus importantes fêtes pour
la foi chrétienne orthodoxe le
gouverneur de la ville avait levé les
restrictions de couvre-feu pour
permettre aux gens de célébrer la messe
de minuit et avait aussitôt
installé ou imposer à nouveau c c sous
couvre-feu après ces frappes pour
revenir à ces frappes justement nous
avons pu nous entretenir avec le maire
d'odessa à la suite des bombardements
d'hier pour lui il s'agit d'un acte
intentionnel et préméditée de la part de
l'armée je vous propose d'écouter cet
extrait
vous savez que l'agresseur russe ses
occupants ces criminels sont très fiers
de leurs armes
je pense qu'ils ont tout pour savoir
exactement où il frappe c'est pourquoi
je dis que ces frappes sont
intentionnellement fait sur des blocs
résidentiels
parce que si vous parlez au monde entier
de vos armes de haute précision si vous
dites au monde entier que vous effectuez
des fans de haute précision sur des
infrastructures militaires c'est faux ce
ne sont que des mensonges ils ont
effectué des frappes précises sur des
blocs résidentiels où les gens se
préparaient à fêter brac c'est au delà
de l'entendement
vos chaussures au chapeau ni moi n'y
tarek et concernant ses frappes sur au
dessin et qu'on n'avait pas connu
d'ailleurs jusqu'ici est ce que les
autorités sur place estiment qu'elles
découlent des objectifs clairement
énoncée par les rues ce vendredi c'est à
dire établir un corridor allant dans le
sud jusqu'à la transnistrie en moldavie
c'est la question que se posent beaucoup
de personnes ici à puisque cette frappe
vous l'avez dit intervient au lendemain
de ses déclarations russes qui ont fixé
de nouveaux objectifs allant du dombass
jusqu'à jusqu'au sud de l'ukraine et
jusqu'à la transnistrie en moldavie
s'agit-il à travers ses frappes d'un
prélude pour d'autres frappes qui
viserait devenir encore plus importantes
au dessin nul ne le sait mais ce que
l'on sait c'est l'importance que revêt
au dessin aux yeux de la russie que ce
soit d'un point de vue culturel
politique stratégique ou économique ces
frappes qui ont visé au dessin hier à
vienne aussi après
après les frappes qui avaient visé le
navire moskva et qui avait coulé cette
caméra là ce navire amiral ce qu'on a pu
recueillir comme information c'est que
ces frappes étaient les nouvelles
frappes d'hier provenaient d'avions de
chasse positionner en mer caspienne des
avions de chasse et donc de là on peut
dire peut-être qu'il s'agit d'un
changement de stratégie de la part de
l'armée russe avec des tirs venant
d'avions de chasse et non pas de deux
navires positionner au niveau de la mer
noire
merci beaucoup tard et écailles